- You literally are just back
from your honeymoon, right?
- Yes.
- Congratulations,
on getting married.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
How was the honeymoon?
Oh my God.
- Look at that.
Look at that beautiful Ralph Lauren suit.
Thank you.
- Yeah, look at that dress.
I'm sorry, I wasn't looking at you.
Yeah, I was like, she looks beautiful.
- She is. She is a little sweetheart.
And we had an amazing time in Thailand.
- Had you ever been?
- Have you ever been?
- I have been to Thailand a few times.
- Well it takes you about a
full 24 hours to get there.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So it took us a day or two
just to get acclimated to the time.
But we went to this beautiful
resort called San Ava
on this little island in Thailand
for about four or five days.
And then we went to Bangkok,
which is a complete
- Totally different.
- departure from the serenity of San Ava.
- Yeah. is it true that you had to go
to the emergency room,
like right before the wedding?
- I did.
- That's a good start.
- Well, yeah. Tell me about it.
- Yeah.
So it was like, we had this amazing band
play for the rehearsal
dinner the night before.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we had a blast and afterwards
we went into the party bus
to go back to the hotel
and we had music pumping in there
and I'm feeling good.
- Feeling good.
- So I decided I'm gonna start dancing.
And they have those
handles that you hold on
in the party bus,
- To let loose.
try to do this thing
where you like like a gymnast,
like straighten myself out.
And I was like, Oh!"
- Cause we have really good ideas read it.
- Something just happened.
And so, yeah. I felt fun.
I got through that night and
I wake up the next morning
two hours before the wedding
and I couldn't get out of bed.
I literally couldn't stand up,
so I was like what am I gonna do?
Oh my God.
So they had to take me
to the emergency room,
give me a bunch of meds and
shoot me with toradol and...
- Oh my God.
- And it was great.
Everything went great.
I got through the night,
- Of course it was,
You're on toradol
- Dance the night away next
morning after the wedding,
couldn't get out bed again.
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- They had to take me
to the emergency room again the next night
and she's like, "Oh my God,
everything's fine here.
This is like the first day of my marriage.
And I'm wheeling my husband
around in a wheelchair."
I'm already old, way older than she is.
So it wasn't a great start,
- But funny one,
- But,
- memorable.
- I was like, Babe, for better or worse.
- Yeah. You said so, I heard it.